hi guys I'm finally back from New York
and that means that I can get back into
the swing of things and living my own
life except for the fact that I can't
see I'm facing a dilemma either I spend
the next week
signing 35,000 calendars with pictures
of myself in them that are completely
butt-naked or I can delete my channel
run away to Bermuda crush my phone
delete all my social media and live out
my life as a hermit because I will never
have to fulfill my promise that I kept
and I told you guys said I would do or I
could spend the next like two three
months of my life signing for an hour
two hours a day to try to chip away at
the 35,000 so I'm gonna choose to do it
all at once which means unfortunately
that I have to take a bit of a break and
buy a bit of a break means I have to
work my ass off work work this hand off
for 12 hours a day over the next week to
sign 35,000 calendars so I'm gonna do
exactly that and I don't know exactly
how long it's gonna take but I'm just
letting you guys know this that as soon
as I got back I was gonna start signing
because I'm ready to do it and it's all
in a warehouse and I have to go to the
warehouse and live in a warehouse for
the next few days that's what I do so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and thank you everybody so much for
buying these calendars I have no regrets
about doing this campaign I have no
regrets about selling these calendars
for charity because it raised over half
a million dollars for the Cancer
Research Institute but I do have some
regrets about having to sign 35,000
calendars with me naked on them but at
least they'll get to you sooner so
that's what's important so thank you
everybody for understanding I will
probably be streaming posting pictures
while I'm signing it and doing horrible
maddening things because obviously I
will have lost my sanity halfway through
that and I won't be able to finish this
with my mind intact so look forward to
some funny stuff when I lose my
that'll be great alright thank you
everybody for watching and as always
I'll see you in the next video bye bye